hello and welcome to this intelligent
squared plus event with me kavita puri
and i
am so delighted to introduce our guest
tonight
william dalrymple all the way in the
highlands he promises us he has a good
connection
i hope you remain there so william
i mean i'm in the highlands on a very
age
network it's almost as old as the
uh as the 1745 memorial outside so
he's also on his son's mac um so
hopefully um
he can use it but i'd love to tell you a
little bit about william
he is a distinguished historian writer
and author of the
very excellent anarchy
the east india company corporate
violence and the pillage
of an empire his books have won many
awards and prizes
including the duff cooper memorial prize
and the wilson history prize
and he is also the curator of forgotten
masters
indian painting for the east india
company the first
uk exhibition works by indian painters
commissioned by east india company
officials
in the late 18th and 19th centuries
which is currently on display
in london's wallis collection so we'll
be chatting for 40 minutes we would
love your questions which as connor
explained um
you can type in and we will would like
to get through as many as we can
um so william i'd like to begin really
when we
think of the raj we think of this
90-year period which
really is from 1858 to 1947
but in the centuries preceding that the
british were in india not
as a national enterprise as we led to
believe but as a for-profit
one why why has that been forgotten
in the telling of our national narrative
it's very interesting and you're quite
right the um when people think of the
british in india the images that come to
mind are
queen victoria kepling kurzen perhaps
um some smiling maharajah on a lawn on
similar playing croquet with an elephant
in the background or
some merchant ivory film with some
lovely memsable
there are two problems with this one is
that the raj proper
the period when the government uh
controlled
uh an indian colony was as you said only
90 years
1858 to 1947 it's a blink in the eye of
indian history
but the british nation were involved in
india
in a very uh in a growing and
increasingly dominant fashion for 250
years before that from about 1600 from
the elizabeth
first uh up to the reign of queen
victoria
and at that time uh it wasn't the
british government
at all that was uh in control it was a
uh a corporation a for profit
corporation uh
run for no other purpose as any
corporation really is
than to enrich the investors and the
shareholders
and um this corporation that started off
as a
business trading in spices and then
moved to being a business trading in
textiles
suddenly in the mid 18th century
militarized and conquered
the richest empire on earth it's one of
the most unlikely stories in world
history
and for the important period of that
yeah no no
sorry for the for the period of that
conquest
the the corporation was based in one
small
london office but at the time of the
crucial battle of
bassey office was only five windows wide
withdrawn back from the street uh and
for a century after its founding
um the head office only had 35 employees
uh and yet that five window um
building 35 employees commanded the
greatest corporate coup in history
at the takeover of the richest empire in
the world and
and to me that's a far more interesting
far more extraordinary
far more unlikely and certainly more
untold story than the rather familiar
tale of
you know kerzen and the imperial derbar
and all
and all that stuff we're used to seeing
on telly with guys with you know empire
building shorts and solar tobes striding
around
uh beating up indians so it's it's an
oddly forgotten period of history and
it's not just forgotten
by accident the british have a
real problem with failing to
come to terms with the nature of their
empire
in india we still somehow
to believe that our empire was different
other empires that we understand that
the belgians
in the congo were horribly brutal
cutting people's hands off
of course the germans were worse whether
in
uh ion in east africa or whether uh
you know the the the the third reich is
the is the ultimate
um uh satanic empire but no we think
our one was different and that there's
maharaja smiling on the lawn and similar
and there's pretty girls in in tennis
shorts and and all those other images
somehow change the reality of empire but
empire
is never for the colonized it's never
defeated in battle it is for the benefit
of those who who who wage war
defeat other nations then occupy their
countries and this is this is a constant
through history whether it's the romans
in britain
whether it's the vikings in in in the
day law
or whether it's the british in india in
the 18th century
well let's go back to 1599 and give up a
sense of that
story have how what began as a company
to deal in silks and spices
would by 1803 have defeated
the mughal empire tell us some of those
key points
along the way
so this is the reign of elizabeth the
first
uh england we're not talking britain yet
there's no active union so it's england
on its own
uh is a relatively peripheral power on
the edge of europe the rich countries of
france
uh spain uh italy and increasingly
holland which has got its independence
and it is the dutch that provoke
uh the british into forming the east
india company uh because they
send a successful expedition to the
spice islands the melakas what we today
call indonesia
uh the the islands of run and java and
sumatra
to buy spices directly from the
producers
and the english merchants in london
who've got a very successful business
going called the levant company
which buy the same spices through
middlemen
in places like aleppo and cairo and
venice
suddenly realize that they're going to
be out of a job if they don't go direct
to the producers too and that's what
happens they
they found a company one of the world's
first corporations
uh there's a public subscription there's
a meeting in moorgate fields
uh the lord mayor turns up the the the a
lot of the aldermen of the city turn up
it's organized by the
head of the levant company mine called
customer smith
who's in charge and they meet in
moorgate fields which isn't
a grubby tube station uh in those days
but today that is actually
as its name implies uh its fields
surrounding the
founders hall which is a lovely sort of
black and white
half timbered tudor building and in this
meeting
lots of people turn up and offer
subscriptions and if you look at the
list the list survives
uh you know there are the rich of the
city but there's an awful lot of people
who describe themselves
as vintners as skinners as haberdashers
in other words
small london businessmen um and they
invest five pounds and ten pounds
alongside the a thousand pounds
two thousand pounds offered by the
really big investors
and this expedition takes place and off
they sail
to the melakas and to their own surprise
they reach it uh because previous
british attempts to reach it had failed
um
and just as they're sailing into into
port they see a portuguese carrick
sailing out and as the crew of the east
india company vessels are almost
all ex-caribbean pirates they simply the
police vessel put it and move the
contents
of the uh the spices from the hold of
the portuguese carrick
into their uh their ship their ship is
that they had already been a pirate ship
it was called
uh the scourge of malice when they
bought it and in the
one of the first cases of sort of
corporate rebranding they renamed it the
red dragon to make it sound slightly
less expensive
um but they sailed back to london with
with this all this
goods that they've seized and they sell
it for a million pounds
and this is enough to get this business
really going it's a massive profit
and then there's a slight sort of hitch
um over the next 40 years they find that
you know they've
got smaller ships and and much less
uh uh full pockets than the dutch the
dutch this is
this is the age of rembrandt the dutch
are at their peak of their power and
they they really
knock the british out of the monaco they
even send a fleet up the thames at one
point and
start uh uh
canadian the british shipyards and
things so the british say okay fair
enough
you keep spy silence and there's a
little face saving deal whereby
the english get given um
a muddy island in the hudson river
called manhattan which of course in the
long run becomes a rather good
investment but
uh at the time it's it's really just a
facesaver
uh and then um they um
there's a there's a kind of corporate uh
redesign that they
they start have a new a new concept and
they decide to focus
on textiles and the worlds and the
world's greatest
are producing the world's greatest
industrial power at this point
is the mobile empire which is producing
about 40 percent of the world's gdp
at a time when england is is producing
about six percent
of the world's gdp and this is the great
break that makes east india company
they leave the declining business of
spices which the dutch stick to and of
course the dutch then
slowly go into into decline
and uh they they focus on the really
profitable business of textiles in india
bengal particularly bengal has one
million looms
which are producing the world's highest
quality and cheapest
cotton cloth it also has silk it also
has painted textiles like calum curries
these gorgeous hangings
that look beautiful on the four poster
bed in genoa or in paris
uh and by the end of the century the uh
there is such of
indian textiles being shipped around the
the world on english ships that
there's de-industrialization in mexico
because of the sheer quantity of india
being imported
so this is already turning into a global
business and the east india company
which had initially been this slightly
sort of crackpot
outfit run by a bunch of grocers and
one or two big big ship owners turns in
the 18th century into the world's
premier business
making vast profits and
raising the the the profitability of
england england um you know which had
been this peripheral part of europe
becomes very rich uh on on the back of
this and alongside it also of course the
other great source of english wealth
which is the caribbean slave trade so
when you go to one of those gorgeous
national trust houses this summer and
look at the
uh some gorgeous georgian porch that
looks as if uh
colin firth is about to stride out of it
in a pair of
breaches and wade through a lake um i
mean the chances are that if it is built
before the industrial revolution that it
came from the money
um looted in india or or from the
caribbean slave trade and these are
important things that we british need to
know
and you you identify 1765
as a really critical moment when the
east india company
ceased to be a conventional trading
company and
it is in fact uh ends up ruling three of
the most powerful states in india just
explain
how that happened because it didn't
happen with with intent on the on the
on behalf of the east india company did
it
correct so this is the period of great
angle of french rivalry and this is a
very important part of the story
um there is a kind of hundred year war
that goes on between
1715 and 1815 and there are periods of
peace and the wars are called different
things at different times but
this whole uh uh
seizure of great chunks of india is part
of that story
and a piece of intelligence reaches the
east india company that a french fleet
has sailed to india and this turns out
in fact to be a dodgy dossier
it's not true the fleet is actually
sailed to canada by the seven year war
when it when it breaks out does break
out in
ohio and anyone who's seen you know the
last of the mohicans it's that war with
with the
native americans joining french troops
in canada and invading the upwards of
the
ohio the young washington is fighting
this war on behalf of the british
but in the course of all this the east
india company persuades the english
government
to send a royal navy fleet out to india
to follow
the french fleet as they think now when
they arrive off the coast of madras
there's no sign of the french they're
not there
uh and leading the expedition is a
rather embarrassed young officer called
robert clive who
who's been given commander and there are
no french
almost the day they arrive in madras the
news comes
quite unexpectedly and not part of the
original plan at
all that the young new nawab of bengal a
man called suraj
has invaded calcutta uh on the pretext
that the
the the calcutta uh people
rebuilt their defenses without his
permission and this is an excuse for him
to show his
his muscle he takes calcutta and
and famously um throws the survivors of
the siege into a
into a a barrack prison that afterwards
gets called the black hole of calcutta
and many generations of english school
children learn about this is a great
atrocity that india did to
uh to these young british men and it
happened i mean
you know people did die there were far
too many people in the prison it was a
hot summer night there was no water
and a disputed number but you know
probably 20 or 30 people
uh 20 30 corpses are pulled out in the
morning
well when cynthia's clive hears this he
realizes this is his moment
uh rather than sailing back uh
empty-handed with no french
to fight the latter he takes calcutta uh
he then take
then the seven year war does break out
and and he attacks the french
uh uh command in the north which is a
place called chandanagar
and at that point a crucial letter
arrives in his hands
and it's a letter from one of the
biggest bankers in india a man called
the jugget set
and the joke it said says offers him a
deal
he says look i don't like surrogate
either enemies
uh he's threatened to circumcise me uh
unless i lend him money
i will pay you robert clive one million
pounds
if you if you uh uh take if you take uh
him out for me
i will also pay the east india company
one million pounds the client says no
problem at
all and he goes north and the whole
thing is a rig the battle of plasti
which is later told to victorian school
children is this great
victory of english arms is in fact a big
setup the
general of saraj abdullah my jaffa is
also in the jugger sets pay halfway
through the battle when um uh sarajevo
dauda realizes that mirjafa is not
fighting
uh he flees the battlefield he's been
pursued he's killed two data clive
simply walks into the richest treasury
uh in india which is the mashidabad
imperial treasury
full of tax money waiting to go to delhi
the whole of the whole of the mughal
empire
is powered by the revenue raised from
this place
and clive just walks in and fills his
pockets then he fills 40 barges
and floats them down to calcutta and
when he's later asked in parliament
you know how on earth could you justify
enriching yourself he's
this single transaction turns him into
the richest
self-made man in europe uh
he simply replies my lords i'm
astonished at my own moderation
uh and this gets him off the hook um and
that is how for the first time
the east india company turns from simply
a trading power that
that shipped uh indian textiles around
the world
uh into an imperial power uh that owns
great chunks of
territory and in seven years later
there's another battle called the battle
of buxa when they
uh they defeat the mughal emperor and
the nawab of avar the other two big
mogul powers in the north
and by 1765 the east india company binds
to its own surprise
that it's actually the replaced the
mogul empire
as the most powerful force in north
india
and what happens
sorry go over it and it's done that i
think it's worth
explaining how it's done that with with
these huge private armies and that's the
astonishing thing that i found from your
book is that
the east india company manages to take
huge swathes of india using indian
mercenaries
fighting other indians financed
by indians correct
this is the great trick they put off
because they're still you know a small
business but with deep pockets
and the mogul empire has been in decline
for 56 years there's been a huge amount
of civil war everyone's exhausted but
the people who are most
uh upset by this civil war are the
merchants and the bankers because
uh productivity is in decline there's
you know there's cavalry riding around
the country killing people
and the junket sets are only one among a
number
of indian bankers who consider the east
india company to be the least
worst option available uh they don't
like the moguls
that the bengali certainly don't like
the marathas who are these other forces
sweeping up through india conquering
great shots of territory
and what happens is you have a corporate
deal two sets of businessmen
the indian businessmen and bankers
realize that the other
uh the other businessman the east india
company speak the same sort of language
they know that they have to repay debts
on time with interest
now this is something that you know
indian realtors don't always do
and and what you get is a deal
between two corporate groups the indian
bankers
and the and the east india company and
the an east india company
ultimately wins not only because
they have the great new 18th century
military technology which certainly
gives them the edge
in the 1760s and 1770s and early 1780s
about 25 years they have a clear
military edge
but they continue to defeat indian
armies even after indian
indian armies have adopted these new
military techniques because they have
the money
to buy better mercenaries and more
troops
and from about four thousand
indian mercenaries at the time of placi
uh
glassy is fought by british army troops
but it's the last
battle which is fought by the british
army everything after that
is fought by east india company troops
who are brown
uh indians uh and there's a handful of
white officers
and as you said paid for by indian
bankers
so it's quite a trick to have pulled off
and by the
1790s the east india company army is not
just the largest army in india
it is twice the size of the british army
the private security force
we're familiar with big companies having
security forces we know maybe a pistol
or some trenches but the east india
company forces
are the largest modern army in asia
and by 1799 there are exactly 200 000
troops
in the east india company armies at a
time when just before the british army
is about to rearm to fight napoleon
and they have 100 000 troops so this
bizarre thing with a private
army twice the size of a nation's army
there's no parallel to this in history
and and i suppose part of
the east india company's human success
derived from the support it had
from parliament all this while it had a
very
effective lobbying operation under half
its mps were shareholders and it was
bringing in around a third of the
country's revenue and so
very few questions were being asked of
it
so at what point is it that parliament
then intervenes to regulate it
and why that's a very
crucial question and you're right for
the first 170 years from 1600
right up to 1770 the english state uh
gathers uh harvests great sums of money
from the east india company apart from
the employment that it's providing apart
from the profits that it's generating
uh it's also generating huge sums in
income tax
and in customs particularly customs
and i think nearly half the nation's
customs comes from east india company
imports
so no one's asking too many questions
about where this stuff is coming from
but in 1770 after winning the battles of
plassium
and bucks and having then done what
companies will do which is effectively
assets rip
and loot um bengals so this place which
had the one million weavers which is the
if you like the the goose laying the
golden eggs
they they kill the boots they they they
strip the
the goose bear uh they pluck the goose
so
viciously that in 1770 when there's a
famine
there are no reserves anywhere now you
know famine is something that's hap come
to india
many times in its history and and anyone
who reads travel accounts of people
traveling india will will
have come across accounts of terrible
famines it's not something that the east
india company or the british
invent but what's new is that the
company has no grain reserves
indian indian rulers know that in in
years of plenty they must put aside
grain reserves
and they also know that that during a
famine they must provide employment so
a lot of the most beautiful buildings in
india are built by indian rulers
um at a ridiculous scale to provide
employment during famines
most obviously the uh the great impara
in lucknow which is one of the great
buildings
of north india off the tourist trail but
uh spectacular and highly recommend it
to anyone who wants to see fine
18th century indian architecture that is
built by the
nawab of luck now at this period as
famine relief measures and starving
people are given a rupee a day
if they start moving bricks and stone
around and helping build this enormous
building
now the east city company does nothing
of this and as a result
um the numbers have recently sort of
been come down they've been very
detailed reach uh regional studies of
how many people died in this famine but
it's still a million people it's a
million dead bengalis
and i mean sometimes the numbers are
given as three or even five million and
and these now seem to be uh uh unlikely
but you know
vast and horrific uh channel heaps of
bodies
bodies being washed down the ganges dogs
picking up corpses
and this is really horrifying it's death
on such a massive scale
and so unprecedented that for the first
time you get whistleblowers uh you get
people writing accounts and sending it
back anonymously to magazines because
you know there are no
award-winning journalists there are no
kavata puris flying in
to report from the front line or or
raggy omars or their equivalents
um but finally
you get reports turning up in the
spectator of the gentleman's magazine
uh of anonymous correspondence
describing the utter horror
of corpses flies vultures
dogs picking at the things i mean and
and even today these accounts you know
we're used to seeing starvation on on
television and so on but even today
uh these accounts are incredibly
upsetting and lurid
so um then what's their company's
response
they are worried about their profits
because it's a company they now need the
land revenues
generated by indians to buy their
investment to buy the cotton they need
to buy
so they send out their armies to the
villages
and in addition to the corpses which are
lying on the ground through starvation
there are now gibbets put
up in every village and anyone who
doesn't pay their taxes even if they're
starving
is hung and when the news arrives at the
annual general meeting
that the east india company has managed
to gather its taxes
in full despite one million casualties
from the
men the shareholders are so pleased they
vote themselves an increased dividend
from
10 to 12 and a half percent so this is
knowingly celebrating
successful fleecing of indians i mean
it's
in a sense it's the clearest moment when
you see the the you know what this
ultimately boils down to which is piles
of corpses
and then very rich people in london
getting their dividends in their in
their banks
so it continues the same for another
year by 1772 they have stripped the
bones clean
there is nothing left to to to harvest
they can't harvest any more revenue
because there is no more revenue
and when the news of that arrives in
london there is horror
30 banks collapse across europe the
eastern company goes to the newly
founded bank of england but they haven't
got enough money to bail it out
yet it is literally too big to fail it
employs too many people
too much of the country's revenue for
the government allow it
to allow it to to collapse what do they
do they basically
buy a 50 share of it they lend it four
million pounds
and that bails out the east india
company but there is a price to pay and
that is
the regulatory act which means that the
government now overlooks
the the east indica so from this point
it becomes what i suppose today we'd
call a private public private
partnership
and this only the government uh interest
in the company then only increases until
finally
in 1858 following the great uprising
which the indians call the first war of
independence but which the
uh british uh call the india mutinies
though
when another million people die this
time from in action
against the east india company
parliament finally says enough
enough and they effectively nationalized
the company in 1858
and it becomes an entirely
government-run operation but
for the 250 years before that
it isn't a government operation it is a
private enterprise it is it
is like facebook or google or or amazon
amazon i suppose being the closest
uh parallel today well you
you talk about amazon and and you say
the story of the east india company has
never been
more current are there
are there companies today or in recent
times who are just
so powerful who might be worth more than
the gpp of some countries who
can exercise their corporate power in a
way that's similar to the
east india company who can topple
governments for example
or even have senior roles in in
government
do you can you see that can can you see
the ghosts of
east india company in in corporates
today
well of course i mean you know you don't
have to be a kind of you know
a a leftist activist to point to
concrete moments in the last
in the history of the last 60 years when
you have had exactly that i mean the
most famous i suppose
um maybe not as famous as it should be
but uh in in 1950s iran
um there's a democratic election and
mossadeck is elected and one of the
first things he says he's going to do is
nationalize the anglo-persian
world company now when this is announced
the cia
and their mix get to work and this is
not fiction this is not a movie they get
to work and they organize a coup and the
sharb iran
takes over and he doesn't that is anger
persian oil
similar thing happens two years later in
guatemala when another socialist
government comes to
uh comes to power and united fruit
who own 40 percent of their cultural
land of guatemala um
get the cia to perform another coup and
topple the central government wants to
nationalize their interests
and that who um produces the phrase
banana republic
fruits people have been making their
banana empire uh
in guatemala then in 1977 itt
get the cia topple salvador allende and
you get one of the most hideous
dictatorships in latin american history
all those disappeared and the women
looking for their children all that
stuff happens after itt
persuaded the cia to intervene
now in our own time we don't know still
know the full story but the
strong suspicions that uh america
on interest particularly exxon uh had a
lot to do with the invasion of
uh some sayings iraq which of course we
know had nothing to do with 911 911 was
was was al qaeda full of saudis uh it
wasn't saudi arabia that gets invaded
and it was saddam hussein's iraq who
wasn't the enemy of al-qaeda how did
that happen
at least in part it was the lobbying of
exxon
and exxon if it were a country today
would be the 14th richest country
in the world so this is not sort of you
know uh
netflix fantasy that we watch in the
evening to entertain us after our work
this is what
corporations can do and corporations
being very rich
have resources the east india company
created this system
the first time the company has found
influencing
a body legislature is in 1690 only 90
years into its history
and already it's found offering share
options to mps who vote to increase its
monopoly
you mentioned the fact that by the 18th
century about 40 percent of mps have
east india company shares so obviously
they want to clip the wins too badly
but you also get by the end of the 18th
century something even more noxious
which is
returned nabobs who've shipped home
fortunes of 100 200 300 000 pounds from
india
um by rotten boroughs and actually
create a parliamentary faction within
parliament of their own
which can which can you know change
change the votes
because there are 20 30 40 mps who of
the east india company interest
so through lobbying through bribery um
and through just quiet influence the
east india company creates a world for
the first time where a corporate
interest
can turn its interest into
the policy of a government and altering
making the interest of the shareholders
the interest seemed to be the interest
of the state
and that's of course the system that
exists today you know
exxon has you know it's not a it's not a
secret the exxon
employs senators it gives them salaries
to lobby for it
uh and other other businesses like
facebook amazon and google have the same
to protect them from taxes
uh so i mean there are huge differences
obviously amazon does not contain
and does not have fighter jets or
nuclear submarines which would be the
equivalent of the cutting-edge
eastern deca armies of the 18th century
but in in some ways you could argue that
you know
these corporations today are richer
sorry are not richer ah well they are
richer but they're also
more powerful because of surveillance
capitalism you know anyone that's got
their phone on listening to us this
evening may well get east india company
t adverts in their social media feed
tomorrow morning
um you know the the way that our
conversations
can be spied on the way we've all had
these things where
um you know we've mentioned uh a
particular brand
in conversation and bingo's there
tomorrow in your instagram feed or your
facebook or twitter
is exactly the corporation that you
mentioned in conversation
so this is going on and this is a
different sort of power
but it's no it's definitely no lesser
power
and i mean you talk a lot about history
showing this very intimate dance between
the power of the state and the power of
company and that
corporations can be regulated but they
will do everything in their power to
resist
that um and i i just wonder do you think
and and this is something that the
states have been trying to do for 400
years
can governments around the world do you
think effectively regulate the influence
of such
powerful companies today especially when
corporations in the police
political systems are so intertwined
well it's often very subtle and there's
a story
from the company in 1720 that in a way
shows
the nub of this problem today 1720 the
rule of the carnatic
uh comes with his army and surrounds
madras besieges madras
and he says you haven't paid any taxes
for the last 10 years
what's going on you're meant to be my
vassals you're meant to uh
to pay every year and this income it
doesn't send that name it sends out one
guy
and he says he says in perfect persian
look
by all means we understand that you can
invade us you can loot the town
and you can burn down and take
everything we have but
we'll just go and find our company
somewhere else we'll go and do it in
bengal we'll go and do it in bombay
and in a sense this is exactly the
argument that amazon will use today
if you close us down in taxes in england
we'll just move it to northern ireland
if we don't leave taxes in northern
ireland we'll move it to southern
ireland
texas and southern ireland will move it
to spain or the azores or you know
the caribbean or wherever it is uh and
uh and it's the same idea that you know
that corporations can play off nation
states
against each other which is why amazon
today pays no tax
because you know every country wants to
have its employment wants to have the
uh the benefit of having amazon employ
huge sums of huge numbers of people in
this country
i want to go back to what we talked
about at the start and how
the evening your company's role uh in
india has been largely forgotten and our
focus has been very much on the raj
given the recent debate over statues and
knowing what you told us about robert
clive
and actually how he was viewed at the
time during his lifetime
are you surprised that in 2020 that a
statue of him still exists in my tour
outside the foreign commonwealth office
yes frankly i am uh the clive
is is a particularly clear and obvious
case because at the time he was regarded
as an out in that crook
he's an extremely violent and ruthless
man and he was hauled before parliament
uh
accused of insider dealing accused of
all sorts of terrible crimes and
in the end he was he just managed to get
off some of the worst things but
shortly afterwards he cut his own he cut
his own throat he was being reviled
across the country
there was a play on in the haymarket
which which satirized him as lord
vulture
people knew about working on in bengal
and the famine and so on
and you know often people defend the
british empire in general but
particularly the east india company by
saying you know we should judge it by
the standards of the time well
by the standards of the time the east
india company was judged to be brutal
uh and ruthless and violent horace
walpole writes you know we have out
on the the spanish in in mexico they at
least have the excuse of religion
we have done it only for profit uh and
one of the things that cheered me up
most
wading through these horrors was reading
the british newspapers at the time and
the british newspapers
are very sensorious of clyde they regard
clive as a monster
people in britain regarding the muslims
for example the story of lady clive's
ferret having a a 2 500 pound
diamond necklace does rounds across the
country uh that you know
the equivalent of the daily mail in at
this time and
uh and and people are horrified by this
they don't like these nay bobs
so why is the statue of clive there if
he was buried if he committed suicide
was buried in an unmarked grave
and was widely reviled how come that we
have a statue of him outside the
commonwealth
uh therefore there's sort of the
commonwealth outside the foreign office
the answer is that lord cousin
at the height of empire just when the
bengalis were beginning to get the
congress going and beginning to
react against what that been this
division of bengal that created this
massive upsurge of nationalism in in
1905 under cursing he comes home and
it's he
who puts the statue up 120 years after
after clive has died
so rather like the confederate statues
in the southern united states that are
not put
up at the time of the civil war but it
put up in the early 20th century when
the civil rights movement is getting
going
clive is becomes a totem for the for the
edwardians
of the foundation of their great raj
which is now under threat
uh and so i mean he it would be very
hard to think
of a less appropriate figure to be
standing outside our foreign office this
is a man who is convicted by his own uh
letters of massive insider dealing uh of
of massacring populations
of of allowing thousands hundreds of
millions to starve to death
and there he is outside the front office
at the back street of downing street if
boris johnson wants to nip out
and have a walk in the park at lunch
time he puts past the statue
of um of clive
and you know we talk about wanting uh to
have a more modern foreign office you
want to talk about
modern britain which which has it has
its you know a different set of values
from from those of the empire
well in that case we should not have
clive
uh outside the front office very very
very clear he is not figure we should
admire today in any way
and so i mean i'm not one of those who
who calls for you know
the mass destruction of statues across
the country but i think clive
is a particularly egregious case as
someone who was a a monster
uh vicious violent ruthless extremely
effective a remarkable man
i mean i hugely enjoyed writing about
him he's the kind of lord vol
and he has amazing ability to
each time he takes on his enemies
whether it's sriracha on the field of
battle
or whether it's rivals when he comes
home or finally
our fellow mps and and groups of
parliamentarians in parliament
each time he wins he's a brilliant
strategist and in all sorts of ways he's
he's a kind of amazing man to read about
but he's a monster
uh and he and he's he's horrible he's
fascinatingly horrible
and uh he just shouldn't be that put him
in a museum put a plaque it's a great
story do you
uh he i mean i i have tried
to uh get tristram hunt to take him into
the v a but they don't want
i think foreign
i'm not getting this firsthand but
they've been various newspaper articles
written
uh saying that i mean i've certainly
seen in the british high commission in
delhi where i live
uh the you know the forum does try and
present an image of modern britain you
have
pictures of by the singh twins and the
british high commissioners residents
they've taken down the pictures of
warren hastings and clive and they you
know they want to present an image of
modern britain a multicultural
place where people of all ethnicities
can can make their careers
uh and this is not
what clive represents so yeah i mean i
think i think
the foreigners would not oppose i
understand uh the removal of clive to a
museum
hmm but it's possible just i mean it's
so central it's so much the
encapsulation of a big british problem
we like to think of our raj as somehow
romantic
gnts panama hats all the rest of it
and we persuade ourselves that you know
that somehow
ruling other people against their will
and conquering them and exploiting them
and
asset stripping their country and
reducing this is the
the most important statistic india
controlled 40 percent of the world's gdp
when the east india company arrives it
controls 5
of the world's gdp when uh when the
british leave
uh so we reduce india from one of the
richest countries in the world to one of
the poorest countries and that
ultimately is the
is the simple evidence that uh that you
know we were not there to build the
railways
to uh to create universities and
hospitals there were many things that
the good that did come out of it i'm not
i'm not one of the
uh those historians who think that
everything the british did was was was
you know
was uh incredibly awful but uh
cumulatively we reduced a very rich
country to penury
which is why india today is regarded as
a third world country
and it's only now 70 years later
beginning to find its feet and
and and take its place back at the
center of the world economies and
we all know that you know in our own
lifetimes uh that we'll see india and
china
ascend to be the richest countries in
the world along with probably america
but uh uh you know it what stopped that
over the last 100 years the answer is
british imperialism
thank you william i'm i'm not sure how
much the british
public know about the east india company
so i'm
thrilled that you've written your book
and um there's so many points to pick
up in your in your uh last answer so i i
hope
uh people you will put some questions to
william just very briefly just to remind
you
underneath the video screen you'll see a
tab it says ask the question
click on it the text box will drop down
type your question in and if you want
your name to be mentioned please do
type it in the box and then click send
and i hope that we can ask your
questions so
i'm just going to go to one now
um so
someone in our audience says i was
appalled by the level
of violence displayed by the british
under clive and others in india as
described in your book
given the british white supremacy and i
used the phrase as a bit myself
in the subcontinent and elsewhere are
you now
concerned like a growing induced
supremacy
under modi under the influence of the
rss
yes i am and in fact i mean this weekend
i i have suffered an attack of
mr modi's troll factory uh there is a
there are these
these uh call centers full of people who
who respond on behalf of his party in
the rss which is the parent organization
of the bjp
uh and uh there was a uh there's been a
big kerfuffle
um and and it's rather terrifying when
when
uh you know ten thousand paid bloggers
land on your
twitter site and accuse you i've been
accused of being
of being both a communist and a viceroy
and imperialist and an axolite
i mean it's all fairly incoherent but uh
yeah no i am
i am concerned and i'm extremely
confident about india's future
economically
in the long term i think i can't see any
way that india
i mean it would it would take a genius
to to screw up
india's economic rise its return to the
top table
i mean two or three years ago it it
finally overtook the british economy for
the first time
uh since the 18th century but uh it's
going to continue to rise in our own
lifetime we'll see it become many times
larger than the british economy
but politically i am extremely anxious
uh i think the
uh the rss which is a company uh is a
political organization that was founded
uh by people that admired what uh adolf
hitler and the nazis were doing
uh in germany and and the founder of the
rss specifically congratulated
uh hitler on or the nazis on crystal
night
uh and and said we must do what the
uh uh what the germans have done to
their semitic minorities
so the the kind of anti-muslim rhetoric
that you get from the rss has distinct
fascist and nazi
echoes and historically the two are
intimately linked
and yeah i know it really does worry me
and i worry certainly um whether you
know
i would want to stay in a country if it
does start rewriting its constitution i
mean there is
we're now very close to the moment when
modi has enough strength to rewrite the
constitution the wonderful constitution
written for india
in 1947 by ambedkar and nehru and gandhi
and and all that generation of
politicians
and um yes i think you know and
there's also the sensation in india i
think very strongly that
this is a country which has been under
the boot not only of the british but
before that of uh
according to rss mythology certainly of
successive
waves of what they call muslim invaders
and now is the moment and and you do get
this sensation
that people you know want a strong
confident aggressive country enough
passivity enough and that's that's the
kind of cry you get
uh and um i understand it but you know
it's it's a less attractive place to
live in than the
the old india which was secular where
many different nations and many
different
uh ethnicities and many different
religions flourished side by side
influencing each other uh uh
mixing their their festivals together
and so on and it was
indeed that pluralism of the old secular
india that i that i loved so much
uh and i i mean i i i think we're in for
a long
spell if not modi than others like him
um because there is no opposition the
gandhis and the congress party have
collapsed
in an extraordinary manner
i mean william you've lived there for
many decades
do you think that there might be a time
politically that you might
come back to live here yeah
i do frankly um and my wife has you know
um is i think more anxious than i am um
but uh um i mean i don't you know i
don't think
i don't sound like i'm exaggerating it's
you know that india will
continue to be an extraordinary and
wonderful country and and
uh there are many many people who do not
subscribe to the ideologies of the of
the rss
but uh uh i i'm not i'm not sure whether
it's
uh a place that will be as lovely to
live in
uh as it does now
um we have another question what do you
make of shashi tarua's demand for
reparations
well who's a good friend of mine has not
actually made a demand for operations
he he's made a demand for a token
reparation of one pound i think which i
that's a bit of a bargain to me uh
considering the amount of
uh that we that we took from the country
um
but what he does want and this is
entirely fair and right and proper
is acknowledgement by the british of
what they've done
and i as i said throughout this talk
that you know i think it is
a real problem for the british that we
don't know what we did in india we don't
know what we did
in northern ireland we don't know what
we did in great space of the world
and other people do if you go to india
everyone knows the stories of julian
wallabag and other massacres what
happened after
after the mutiny everyone in ireland
knows about the potato family
everyone in australia knows what
happened to the indigenous australians
believe that you know the complete
extinction of the tasmanian aborigines
um we are not taught this stuff and if
you go through a british education
system
even if you are a historian at a level
you can get through the entire thing
and only hear about uh you move from
henry viii
to hitler with a brief stop on the way
for
for um for wilberforce and florence
nightingale
um so the impression is given that you
know we've always been the side of the
angels again we have the merchant ivory
india of croquet and maharajas and
elephants
and it's all absolutely lovely now the
truth is no you know we were involved
throughout the world
uh in in mass atrocities we wiped out
whole peoples we we
um innumerable massacres on every
continent now
i'm not asking for a massive sort of
exercise in nation
in national chess beating but we need to
know this stuff and when we go abroad we
need to know what other people know
about us uh and and we're just not
taught it at the moment it's not on our
curriculum
at all um and we need to get it on the
curriculum because i mean
just to give you a concrete example when
when um theresa may
came out to india um after the brexit
vote
the idea was was current both in the
tory party and in the civil service that
somehow having fallen out with our
european friends that we could go back
to the empire we go back to the
australians to new zealand we
particularly go back to india they love
us in india
and of course they're going to want to
be our friends now and they probably
want the empire back
you know when teresa may arrive there of
course
absolute fantasy of course they want
their back of course they feel
uh that uh there was no favors at all
they're quite happy to do business with
us and if we offer them
um nice visa regulations and places at
our universities and all the things they
want they would be very happy to to do
business with us but there's no
sensation that
they're longing for the return of
theresa may as the viceren or the
empress of india
and quite the opposite i think you know
the younger generation of indians feel
extremely
uh upset about imperial history they
read shashi thorough and they read about
the terrible things that happened
and they want to uh and they want us to
watch it
and the fact there's only last year that
the archbishopri finally went down in
his
monuments you know which is a
straightforward massive amount of people
by british troops it's very black and
white there's absolutely no grey
area in there it was a terrible terrible
thing it should be very simple to
apologize for
but successive royal tours and prime
ministerial tours have gone to amritsar
have visited the site of the massacre
have laid a wreath but not apologized
uh and that seems to me to me to be you
know just putting
salt and vinegar in the wounds
either ignore the issue altogether or
apologize
and we need to have it in our schools
and i've seen succession
of british high commissioners coming out
highly educated men brilliant
class stoppers who you know got first at
oxford and cambridge and have brilliant
careers coming out and again they kind
of slightly assume that they're going to
be
you know loved throughout india because
of the raj
and it just ain't so um indians
you know quite happy to be our friends
they a lot of them grow up watching bbc
tv series though that's disappearing the
parents generation used to listen to the
world service so that's also
on the decline many of them went to
british universities so that is now in
serious decline since
that we we throw them out of the country
two weeks after their finals
uh they haven't got a job by then um
and you know we we need to wise up a bit
to this
uh there are many things that it is a
place we can certainly do business it's
a place where we can appeal to a great
deal of shared
interests and tastes and histories um
but we need to we need to realize what
we
what we've done to that country we need
to realize the degree to which
our wealth was built on on the
extraction
of wealth from india and to that point
uh mayor patel asked
how can this true narrative be brought
into the classroom in the uk in place of
the sanitized
history currently taught you know empire
is a very incendiary issue in britain
so how how do we introduce it within the
school system then
well i'm not an expert on on how to get
things through the political system in
this country and probably you cavator
would be in a better position to answer
that question than i would but i would
imagine
lobbying mps uh and making your voice
heard
at the moment i mean we saw only
yesterday um
boris johnson uh uh crying for
uh land of hope and glory and and all
the imperial chants at the proms now
to someone like that i think you know
all this is just sort of leftist
whinging
um as a and and there is this default
position
uh by people like boris that that uh
you know the empire was this wonderful
thing he went started quoting kipling
when he went to
burma mandalay which you know uh is
rather like sort of quoting
sort of uh nazi marching tunes when
visiting
uh auschwitz or something it's it's
fantastically inappropriate really quite
fantastically insulting
um and it's quite it's very clear that
boris and gov
do not get this both of them have this
default idea that the british empire was
something wonderful and frankly they
need to read a little more history
but i do think i think it's actually
damaging our nation's interests at the
moment this national amnesia
the germans are very good at the way
that they have
faced up to their past they teach the
horrors of uh that they committed
at school and young germans can walk out
in the world in the world without that
damage
without that baggage sorry uh around
their shoulders
um our our youth our kids at school
remain totally ignorant about what we
did wrong
and and we need to know it
last question to what extent are indians
culpable in letting the east india
company attain
so much power and influence
well there's no question that there was
a great deal of collaboration
and i mean when i give this talk
in england i tend to emphasize the
culpability of the british and the and
the degree to which
you know we did terrible things that
were not taught at school when i give
this talk in india
i mentioned exactly what you just
mentioned the fact that the jagged sets
paid clive to fight the battle of
plassey the fact that it was
uh the loans of indian bankers and
indian troops who fought the battles
so it's a far more complex picture and
many many indians particularly the
bengalis
regarded the east india companies the
least worst option uh in
in the horrific anarchy of 18th century
india so
you can make that case and historically
i think that's that holds up and i and i
certainly
write a lot about that in india but it
doesn't alter the fact
that uh that we also need to understand
the the terrible things that happened
and the sheer amount of wealth which
flowed
i mean individually in the late 1770s
and 1780s
uh you know three or four or 500 000
pounds a year
were flowing out of india into british
bank accounts
uh to the extent that you know silver
and gold began running out in bengal
because there simply wasn't any left so
much was being shipped abroad
um so yeah i know it's a complicated
story it's not black and white
um one of the reasons people like these
cindy company was that so many of the
mogul and morata rulers
um did terrible atrocities too and and
i've tried to
um be balanced about this i mean there
are many monsters in this book and not
all of them are
our east india company officials um
and and i think what you've said is is
it's an important point
history is complicated history is not
full of uh angels and villains it's it's
full of
many many shades of grey and i very much
tried to show that in this book but uh
um it's not a pretty tale and the fact
that our
empire in india was founded entirely for
the profit of shareholders
is something that very very few people
think have taken in i mean they knew it
in 18th century there was
absolutely no no
everyone understood the east india
company to be a monstrously powerful
and monstrously extractive organization
that created huge fortunes for a small
number of people
over the dead bodies of lots of indians
this was widely known
and east india company officials were
extremely unpopular in 18th century
britain but somehow
the victorian whitewash of this that
took place during the year
of cousin in the early 20th century has
left this
uh the country with widespread amnesia
about this and
it's time to correct it and that's in a
sense why i wrote this book
well william thank you and i'm really
glad you wrote this book it is
an incredible read it might take some
time but it's worth it
um
um i'm so glad that connection remained
from the highlands
you can go back now
thank you all for joining us um